T
THE NEW EPISODE OF
"TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS,"
CALLED "THE UFO FILES," YOU CAN
STREAM IT RIGHT NOW IN THE
FOXNation.com.
WE TOLD YOU BANK OF AMERICA HAS
BEEN TURNING OVER PRIVATE
CUSTOMER DATA TO THE FEDS AS
PART OF ITS EFFORTS TO SPEED
EXTREMISM, NOW WE ARE LEARNING
THAT BANK OF AMERICA ITSELF HAS
EXTREMIST VIEWS ITSELF.
BANK OF AMERICA IS TEACHING
TODDLERS CAN BE RACIST.
ACCORDING TO BANK OF AMERICA,
"TODDLERS DEVELOP RACIST BIAS BY
AGE 3-5 AND SHOULD BE TAUGHT TO
RECOGNIZE THE SMOG OF WHITE
PRIVILEGE."
BOB BEASLEY, THAT IS THE
CREEPIEST, SCARIEST, MOST EVIL
THING WE HAVE HEARD TODAY.
CHRIS RUFO WROTE THIS STORY AND
JOINS US TONIGHT.
CHRIS, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THIS IS SHOCKING.
BANK OF AMERICA IS ENDORSING
THIS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, IN THE TRAINING
PROGRAM.
BANK OF AMERICA DENOUNCES
AMERICA AS A WHITES PREMISES
COUNTRY, AND BY EXTENSION
EXPRESSES ANTIPATHY AND
HATRED TO 70% OF ITS CITIZENS, A
PATTERN AMONG OUR FORTUNE 100
COUNTRIES, ADOPTING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
THE MOST RADICAL CRITICAL RACE
THEORY COURSES IN OUR ELITE
UNIVERSITIES.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, WHAT DO
THEY SAY -- THEY ARE TEACHING
PEOPLE THAT WHITE CHILDREN ARE
INHERENTLY EVIL AND RACIST, AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES JUST KIND OF SIT
THERE AND NOT?
IS ANYONE SAYING I'M NOT PUTTING
UP WITH THIS ANYMORE?
IF YOU SAID THIS ABOUT ANY OTHER
GROUP IT WOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
AS ANYONE FOUGHT BACK?
>> YOU KNOW, FROM THE SOURCES
WHO LEAKED ME THIS MATERIAL,
THEY FOUGHT BACK THROUGH ME BY
SHARING THE DOCUMENTS SO I COULD
EXPOSE THEM TO THE PUBLIC, BUT
HERE'S THE THING.
IN CORPORATE AMERICA, PEOPLE ARE
SCARED FOR THEIR JOBS, THEY ARE
SCARED FOR THEIR REPUTATIONS,
THEY ARE SCARED FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
THIS IS THE NEW DOMINANT
IDEOLOGY IN WORKPLACES AND
UNIVERSITIES, K-12 SCHOOLS,
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED TO STAND UP
BECAUSE THEY SEE THAT AMERICANS
WHO DO STAND UP FOR THE VERY
SIMPLE TRUTH, THAT WE SHOULD ALL
BE TREATED EQUALLY, REGARDLESS
OF OUR SKIN COLOR, ARE NOW
TREATED AS ENEMIES OF OUR
LARGEST INSTITUTIONS.
THEY WILL BE HELD UP HER
MOCKERY, SHAME, HUMILIATION, AND
IT IS UP TO US TO STAND UP,
THOSE OF US HAVE A PLATFORM,
BECAUSE THIS IDEOLOGY IS SEEPING
INTO OUR INSTITUTIONS AND SEEKS
TO DESTROY THE VERY FOUNDATIONAL
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES OF THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I MEAN, WE ARE TURNING INTO
RWANDA.
IT'S REALLY SICK, AND YOU HAVE
BEEN BRAVE AND RELENTLESS ANTICS
IN EXPOSIN